es ist wichtig zu erkennen dass die
Angriffe der Hamas nicht im luftleeren
Raum stattfanden das palästinensische
Volk war 56 Jahre lang einer
erdrückenden Besatzung
ausgesetzt es hat miterlebt wie sein
Land durch Siedlung diezimiert wurde und
von gewalteim gesucht wurde die
Wirtschaft im Niedergang sich befand die
Menschen vertrieben wurden und ihre
Häuser zerstört wurden ihre Hoffnung auf
eine politische Lösung sind geschwunden
das Leid des palästinensischen Volk kann
die fürchlichen Angriffe der Hamas nicht
rechtfertigen aber diese fürchlichen
Angriffe können auch die kollektive
Bestrafung des palästinensischen Volkes
nicht rechtfertigen ich bin zutiefst
besorgt über die eindeutigen Verstöße
gegen das humanitäre Völkerrecht die wir
in Gaza beobachten lassen Sie mich es
klar sagen keine Partei in einem
bewaffneten Konflikt steht über dem
internationalen humanitären
recht
[Musik]
die paläsenser haben Gasa
bekommen aber sie nehmen das
Geld und anstatt dass sie damit
Krankenhäuser bauen oder Einkaufszentren
oder Bürogebäude nehmen sie das Geld um
raketenfabriken zu gebauen oder ein
Tunnelsystem zu errichten sie haben
dieses Geld zweckentfremdet und nie der
Bevölkerung zukommen lassen das ist nur
ein Beispiel und all die Videos zeigen
wie stolz sie auf ihr Massaker
sind das kann man nicht im Namen des
Islams tun menschliche Werte oder der
Kampf nach Freiheit sie sprechen im
Namen von
Grausamkeit dem Bösen Hass und meine
verehrten Damen und Herren sie sollten
sich alle
fragen worum geht es hier wir haben
nicht nur das Recht uns zu verteidigen
wir haben sogar die Pflicht es ist kein
Recht es ist eine
Verpflichtung und ich richte mich an sie
alle und sage Ihnen das folgende das
Schlimmste kommt
noch
dieser Krieg ist uns
aufoktruiert worden dieser Krieg ist uns
auf erlegt worden es ist nicht nur
israelskrieg es ist ein Krieg der freien
Welt es geht hier auch immer gibt diesen
diese Bitte nach
Verhältnismäßigkeit es gab die Rufe nach
einer
Ruhe wie sieht eine angemessene Reaktion
auf das Töten von Säuglingen aus wenn
man Frauen vergewaltigt und sie
verbrennt wenn man ein Baby köpft wie
sieht da eine angemessene Reaktion aus
wie kann man eine Waffenruhe vereinbaren
und gewähren wenn jemand sagt eure
Existenz soll vernichtet werden wie
sieht eine verhältnismäßige Antwort auf
dieses Massaker vom 7 Oktober aus es
geht um die völlige
Vernichtung der Hamas es ist nicht nur
das Recht Israels die Hamas zu
vernichten es ist unsere
Pflicht mehr als 2 Millionen
Palästinenser kämpfen ums Überleben
jeden Tag jede Nacht wenn die Vertreter
hier fertig sind am Ende ihrer reden
werden
weitere Palästinenser getötet worden
sein darunter 60 Kinder in den letzten
beiden Wochen wurden mehr als
Palästinenser getötet mehr als 2300
Kinder und mehr als 1000 Frauen im
Vergleich zur bevölgung Gazas wären das
154 000 britische Bürger oder mehr als
700000 amerikanischen Bürger alle die
Israel cht hat sind Zivilisten mehr als
eine Million vertrieben 170 000
Wohnungen zerstört
Exzellenz nur das Völkerrecht und der
internationalen Friede verdienen ihre
Unterstützung mehr Ungerechtigkeit und
mehr Tote werden Israel nicht sicherer
machen keine Waffen und keine Allianz
wird Israel Sicherheit ben nur der
Frieden Frieden mit Palästina und seinen
Menschen das Schicksal der
Palästinenser kann nicht in Vertreibung
und Leugnung ihrer Rechte und in tote
bestehen wir brauchen ein gemeinsamen
Frieden und eine gemeinsame Sicherheit
sie sprachen alle von dem legitimen Leid
des palästinensischen Volkes ihren
legitimen Bestrebung helfen Sie ihm das
ichen unterstützen die die Umsetzung
dieser Bestrebungen diejenigen die eine
noch größere humanitäre Katastrophe
vermeiden wollen und dass sich das Ganze
ausbreitet in der Region für die muss
klar sein dass jetzt der israelische
Krieg gegen das palästinensische Volk im
gazaastreifen beendet werden musste
stoppen sie das Blut
vergießen für Deutschland ist Israels
Sicherheit nicht
verhandelbar wie jeder andere Staat in
der Welt hat Israel das Recht sich zu
verteidigen gegen den Terrorismus
innerhalb des
Völkerrechtes sich um das Leid der
Palästinenser zu kümmern steht überhaupt
nicht im Widerspruch zu dieser klaren
unerschütterlichen Position sondern ist
ein wesentlicher Teil davon in Israel
hat man mir Videos
gezeigt von den
unvorstellbaren
Brutalitäten der hamase gegenüber
Menschen junge Mädchen die auf
LKWs geworfen wurden als Geisen stellen
wir uns
vor das wären meine oder ihre Kinder
alle Geisel müssen sofort freigelassen
werden und ich bedanke mich bei allen
die nonst daran
arbeiten in Jordanien habe ich eine
palästinensische Flüchtlingsfamilie
getroffen Schulmädchen haben mir gesagt
dass 53 ihrer Angehörige und Freunde in
Gasa in den letzten Tagen ums Leben
gekommen sind
53 jeder von denen war die Tochter oder
der Sohn von Menschen stell war ihre
Tochter oder ihr Sohn alle zivilen Leben
zählen gleichermaßen die Menschlichkeit
ist universell und das sollte auch für
unser Mitgefühl gelten der Kampf gilt
der Hamas und nicht der
Zivilbevölkerung daher ist es wichtig
für uns dass dieser Kampf auf der
Grundlage des humanitären rechtes
erfolgte mit größtmöglicher Rücksicht
auf die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza deshalb
stockt Deutschland seine humanitäre
Hilfe für Gaza um 50 Millionen auf 19
Millionen davon gehen an die
unra deshalb brauchen wir humanitäre
Fenster damit diejenigen die Leiden
Hilfe bekommen können in Gaza und dabei
dürfen wir uns nicht an der Nase
rumführen lassen durch das Drehbuch der
Hamas die Hamas spielt mit
Leid und nutzt Frauen und Kinder in Gaza
als menschliche
Schutzschilde sie versteckt ihre Waffen
unter Wohnblocks unter Supermärkten auch
unter Krankenhäusern und das ganz
bewusst sie wollen die Flammen des
Hasses und der Gewalt anfachen regionale
Eskalation zünden und uns als
Weltgemeinschaft zerreien wir können uns
entscheiden den Konflikt nur durch
unsere eigenen Augen zu sehen und dem
Leid und der Wut
nachzugeben oder wir können gemeinsam
vorangehen selbst wenn wir nur kleine
Schnitte Unternehmen damit die Hamas
niemals wieder derartige
terrorhandlungen begehen kann die Regeln
der unokarta und des volökerrechtes
sollten unsere Arbeit für ein neues
morgen leiten einen sinnvollen Friedens
der den Israelis und Palästinensern
ermöglicht nebeneinander zu Leben in
Frieden und Sicherheit in zwei
unabhängigen
Staaten wir wissen der Frieden
funktioniert nur wenn er für alle
funktioniert